[Musique]
des bulles papales ou des décisions
papales du 15e siècle établissait que
les terres du Nouveau Monde
n'appartenaient à personne ce qui a
permis le pillage des terres autochtones
et ses richesses du nord au sud du
continent les États européens qui vont
découvrir des terres non habitées par
des chrétiens vont pouvoir en prendre
possession
s'ils soutiennent l'oeuvre missionnaire
en même temps donc le pape leur fait un
peu un marché laissez-les lors de la
visite du pape François au Canada en
juillet dernier il a renouvelé ses
excuses pour l'implication de l'Église
dans le système des pensionnats pour
autochtones mais il s'est abstenu de
condamner la doctrine de la découverte
mais le Vatican dans une déclaration
officielle corrige le tir et estime que
cette théorie de la doctrine de la
découverte n'est pas considéré comme une
expression de la foi catholique une
annonce attendue depuis longtemps
la grande église le dire et moi je suis
convaincu que ça l'a influencé la racine
du droit ici au Canada même si les gens
me disent non le vertical reconnaître
que ces documents et caduques et abrogé
et quelque chose qui n'est plus en
vigueur et les Canadiens maintenant le
gouvernement de Canada doit vraiment
s'asseoir un négocier de bons fois
malgré l'importance de la décision du
Vatican cette expert qualifie le geste
de symbolique sur le plan
constitutionnel on s'attend pas à ce que
cette étudiation là est un impact
juridique concret sur les enjeux
territoriaux par exemple symbolique ou
pas cette condamnation de la doctrine de
la découverte est une correction
historique précieuse pour les peuples
autochtones
ici Jacques bissonner Radio-Canada
Montréal